Rose a difficult tournament up to at
this point but you keep on fighting and
keep on fighting keep putting forward
your best chest tell us about your
experience here at St Lucia's love so
far
been pretty enjoyable obviously I wish
the tournament would have gone a bit
better for me but there's still three
rounds left
let's talk about the critical moments of
your tournament what would you say those
were and how did they impact your
performance so far well like when I held
that tough position against Carissa I
think gave me some confidence
and when I lost those three games in a
row that was difficult how do you
recover from those
painful losses well the rest they helped
obviously yes I mean mostly I just try
to pretend like the next games in the
tournament are like
as separate tournaments if you get what
I mean yeah absolutely now what I really
like about you is that you always post
your thoughts also on Twitter and social
media you definitely create that
connection with your fans do you enjoy
that and tell us a bit about that well
basically I just post after every
Tournament game because it seemed like
everyone is interested in how I did so I
just write a short tweet sort of
explaining a bit oh I think that's a
great way to externalize your feelings
let's say guys any questions for Rose
just an observation Rose I thought that
you played incredibly well out of the
opening light you're really you you your
preparation was great How Deeply did you
prepare for this brayer you it was
amazing
um maybe my preparation ended around
B3 uh sorry B3 after Bishop D2 because
you've been following you know top top
Grandmaster games
right up well
at B3 yes that's pretty deep yeah
um
because I mean I've played the brayer
myself and it's like you you were
playing it like like you've done this
your whole life or something it's pretty
impressive
thank you yeah that's actually my
question you are just 14 years old and
you qualified for this incredible
tournament I mean it's for girls under
20 years old so you can play it at least
five more times uh how does that feel to
be this young and already qualifying for
I mean such an incredible term and here
in St Louis well it feels nice I mean
even if this one is not going exactly
the way I hope that I'll still have many
more chances right better so I like it
and on that note I read that this year
it was your first time that you won in a
classical chess against a grand master
how do you think about yourself in terms
of in terms of like just progress that
like you're still you know improving
with every tournament
yeah I think I'm still improving
definitely I hope so
I mean what do you beat the grand
Masters at 14 years of age you must be
feeling quite good about your chest and
your husband and now they're nowadays
there are like Grand Masters who are
already there are people who are who
already are Grandmasters like 13.
is he one of your
let's say Idols or like you've been
looking up to him as he was growing up
through the ranks uh yeah definitely I
even got his book at home I had he
became a grand master very nice very
nice
well congratulations Rose absolutely and
uh we're gonna be uh hearing your name
and watching a lot of your tournament
games for years to come good luck thanks
Mike good luck
and I mean come on